what have I been saying about
single-payer health care and Democrats
for months now I have been saying make
Medicare for all or some version of
single-payer part of the Democratic
platform HR 676 was introduced in the
house in January Medicare for all barely
a ripple told you yesterday senator
Bernie Sanders will introduce something
in the Senate for single-payer health
care hopefully that gets more attention
although it's not clear there are now
some Democrats running in the 2018
midterms on single-payer health care and
I guess they're getting some attention
one is Randy Bryce who's an ironworker
he's running against Paul Ryan in
Wisconsin so he's got quite an uphill
battle going he's pushing Medicare for
all his first campaign video was
actually about health care and it went
viral he's off to an interesting start
Amy vilela is primary a Democrat in
Nevada because the Democrat incumbent
didn't sign on to Medicare for all she
actually lost her 22 year old daughter
tragically a few years ago alleging that
hospital staff didn't treat her
daughter's blood clot because she didn't
have insurance clot traveled to her
lungs and ultimately caused a fumble
pulmonary embolism you've then got days
been AK for the michigan sixth District
also running on universal health care
and Dorothea gask is running in
Washington's third congressional
district I don't know if these people
have a shot right but I do believe that
unless the Democratic Party makes this
part of its platform individuals running
on single-payer particularly non
incumbents aren't going to benefit that
much from it because you've got these
sporadic individuals saying I'm running
on single-payer if it's just the
sporadic support I don't know Pat how
much of it how much of an impact it's
going to have I believe that the
Democrats really should make this part
of the platform it doesn't matter that
you're not going to get it with a Trump
administration without Republican House
and Senate make it part of your platform
you can't run a 2018 midterm campaign on
just defending Obamacare alone right
because what is that the status quo it's
the same effect that Hillary Clinton
tried to go after right just keeping
things the way that they are the way
that Republicans were able to win
elections in two
in 2014 and 2016 were by going on a
proposition right to repeal Obamacare
you actually do something else I
completely agree with you and compounded
with that is the problem of sort of a
general lack of public awareness of
what's going on on paper 33 percent of
Americans support single-payer that's an
increase since January of 5% according
to a new Pew poll from last month that
might suggest a lot of people just don't
know what single-payer means because the
exact same survey showed that 60% of
Americans believe the federal government
should provide health care to all
Americans but only 33 percent of
Americans are for single-payer and that
is part of single-payer being a kind of
awkward phrase and I think that
universal health care is much more
appealing and clear Medicare for all I
think is much more appealing and clear
and single-payer is both confusing and
it sounds may be more costly and I think
it continues to be a messaging issue as
well if you phrase this poll question as
do you support Medicare for all I'm sure
those numbers would be a lot higher
especially because as an entitlement
program it's the second most popular one
it's at like 77 percent and people know
what it is so I think though that number
sixty percent even higher would be the
result of that one other idea I want to
propose Pat if you will allow it Donald
Trump has historically been in favor of
single-payer health care not shocking
since he's taken most positions on most
issues at some point in his life Trump
has had failure after failure on the
Obamacare repeal and replace
Trump's promise was get rid of the
Obamacare program and replace it with
something beautiful that will work for
everybody what if some Democrats
privately reached out to Trump and said
listen we want to work with you to give
you a major success in keeping a
campaign promise and doing something
really good let's work together on
Medicare for all you would only need
some Republicans to come to your side
it's insanely unlikely but Trump is nuts
it could actually work couldn't it maybe
every Donald Trump doesn't really know
what he's talking about when it comes to
health care and we know that he's easily
persuaded I mean he was like a Democrat
until you know twenty years ago a few
years ago and really found birtherism
right so he could go along with it
your thoughts what about that thanks for
joining us on the bonus show different
bonus show today because of our full
interview with Peter Boghossian on the
broadcast show back to the normal setup
tomorrow today's program is made
possible in part by taga dev the hosting
specialist they host websites for
everybody from bloggers to businesses to
financial traders you can get virtual
dedicated and private server solutions
cloud server solutions custom server
solutions whatever is right for your
project or business is available at taga
deb and with a growing number of people
increasingly interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is offering our viewers and
listeners a twenty british pound free
credit when you sign up to give you a
chance to try out their cloud server
solution this is a limited availability
offer first-come first-served for
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and use the discount code TV
PS 20 during your account registration
twenty British pounds roughly twenty
three twenty four US dollars once again
check it out sign-up tag adapt calm /td
PS the discount code is TDPS twenty